.
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THE VOTERS
BE DAMNED.
DESPITE DEMOCRATS BEING ON THE
VERGE OF LOSING IN THE HOUSE AND
A WHOPPING 75% SAYING THE
COUNTRY IS HEADED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, THE BIG GUY SAYS HE
WON'T BE CHANGING ANYTHING
UNLESS IT IS HIS PARENTS.
>> WHAT IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS DO
YOU INTEND TO DO DIFFERENTLY TO
CHANGE PEOPLE'S OPINION OF THE
DIRECTION OF A COUNTRY,
PARTICULARLY AS YOU CONTEMPLATE
A RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024?
>> NOTHING BECAUSE THEY ARE JUST
FINDING OUT WHAT WE ARE DOING.
THE MORE THEY KNOW ABOUT WHAT WE
ARE DOING, THE MORE SUPPORT
THERE IS.
>> Greg: OKAY.
BIDEN'S VOW TO STICK TO HIS GUNS
POST-MIDTERMS IS GETTING CALLED
OUT BY HIS PALS IN THE MEDIA.
>> WHEN HE WAS ASKED, WOULD YOU
CHANGE ANYTHING, HE SAID NO.
NOW YOU HAVE 75% OF THE COUNTRY
SAYING WE ARE HEADED IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
HE SAID HE JUST WOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT BECAUSE, OF
COURSE, OUR ACHIEVEMENTS TAKE A
LONG TIME TO BE RECOGNIZED.
THAT IS INSULTING PEOPLE.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WAS A
GOOD ANSWER FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: AND AFTER
RELENTLESSLY ATTACKING
REPUBLICANS AS THE GREATEST
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, BIDEN NOW
SAYS HE IS OPEN TO WORKING WITH
THEM.
FUNNY.
>> LOOK, I ALSO THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SENT A MESSAGE
THAT THEY WANT US TO WORK
TOGETHER.
I HAVE ALWAYS DONE THAT.
I KNOW I GOT CRITICIZED FOR IT
WHEN I RAN.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE FINAL
TALLY SHOWS, I AM WILLING TO
WORK WITH REPUBLICANS, BUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE MADE IT CLEAR.
THEY EXPECT REPUBLICANS TO WORK
WITH ME, AS WELL.
>> Greg: DAY NOW, DANA, DANA,
THIS DRIVES ME NUTS BECAUSE I
ALWAYS GO BACK TO THAT DEBATE
BETWEEN HIM AND NO MATTER
WHAT HE CALLED A RACIST, SHE
CALLED HIM A RACIST COMMENT
AFTERWARDS, IT IS JUST A DEBATE,
WE ARE GOING TO WORK TOGETHER.
>> Dana: AND WORK TOGETHER.
>> Greg: ALSO, THE BIGGEST
START TO SOCIETY, CIVILIZATION,
DEMOCRACY, BUT MAYBE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER AFTERWARDS.
>> Dana: PEOPLE HAVE LONGER
HIS MEMORIES NOWADAYS, MIGHT BE
ALL THE SUPPLEMENTS AND
NUTRITION THAT HAVE IMPROVED.
I FEEL BIDEN SEEMS TO THINK THE
DEMOCRATS HAD A BETTER NIGHT
THAN EXPECTED BECAUSE OF HIM,
NOT IN SPITE OF HIM.
AND WHETHER HE LIKES TO THINK
ABOUT THIS OR NOT, WASHINGTON IS
CHANGED, AS OF THIS MOMENT,
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE HOUSE
MAJORITY IS GOING TO CHANGE,
POSSIBLY THE SENATE, AND SO THAT
DOES -- IT HAS AN EFFECT OF
FOCUSING A MIND.
THE OTHER THING IT DOES IS IT
MAKES THE MEDIA HAVE TO FOLLOW
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT.
AND WHEN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, WHEN WE LOST THE
MAJORITY IN THE 2006 MIDTERM,
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY ALL OF THE
ATTENTION WENT TO THE HILL, AND
THEY DROVE ALL OF THE NEWS
BECAUSE IT WAS AN ADVERSARIAL
THING.
OR IT WAS DIFFERENT, THERE WAS A
CONTRAST.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THE MEDIA DOES
WITH IT, TUNE IN HERE TO FIND
OUT OTHER THINGS, BUT I DO
BELIEVE HE WILL TRY TO CONTINUE
TO DO THINGS THAT ARE ILLEGAL.
AND WE ARE GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT LATER, BUT HE KNOWS
THAT THE STUDENT LOAN
FORGIVENESS IS ILLEGAL, BUT THEY
DID IT ANYWAY, BUT NOW THEY WILL
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DEAL
WITH IT, SO I DO NOT KNOW HOW HE
PLANS TO SAY, OKAY, I AM GOING
TO DO THIS THING THAT YOU SAY
THAT YOU HATE THAT YOU HAVE TO
WORK WITH ME ON IT -- HOW DO YOU
WORK WITH SOMEONE WHEN YOU KNOW
IT IS ILLEGAL?
THERE IS NO COMPROMISE THERE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
JUDGE, HE SAYS HE IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE, IS THAT ARROGANT OR
JUST CLUELESS?
>> Jeanine: IT IS ARROGANT,
TONE-DEAF, CLUELESS, STUPID, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE, I CAN GET
MY THESAURUS OUT FOR THAT ONE.
THIS MAN IS SO DELUSIONAL, HE
REALLY THINKS THEY DID A GREAT
JOB.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT, YOU HAVE TO, YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE WAS PREDICTING A RED
WAVE, WHEN WE REALLY HAVE TO
ASK, WHO WERE THE POLLSTERS WHO
PREDICTED THE RED WAVE?
WHY IS DATA COLLECTION
DIFFERENT?
WHY ARE THEY TELLING US THINGS
THAT ARE NOT ACTUALLY HAPPENING?
>> Greg: IT WAS PRETTY CLOSE.
>> Jessica: OVERALL, THE STATE
OF POLLING WAS EXCEPTIONALLY
ACCURATE.
>> Jeanine: WELL, WHO CAME --
>> Jessica: THERE WERE OUTLIER
POLLS.
>> Greg: JESSE.
>> Jessica: NOT JUST JESSE.
>> Jesse: OVERWEIGHTED
REPUBLICAN, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE GENERIC CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOT, THEY HAD REPUBLICANS
PLUS 2.5%, AND IT ENDED UP BEING
REPUBLICANS PLUS 6%.
REPUBLICANS ARE WINNING 52-46.
THAT IS A SIX-POINT MARGIN.
NO ONE HAD THAT.
THEY ARE WINNING BY MORE THAN
6 MILLION VOTES.
NATIONALLY.
SO THAT IS A RED WAVE, ACTUALLY,
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT IS
GERRYMANDERED, YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO GET A LOT OF TOSS UPS IN THE
SEATS THAT ARE UP FOR GRABS.
>> Jessica: CAN I FINISH?
>> Greg: THE RED WAVE WENT IN
THE WRONG SPOT, LIKE IN THE
BASEMENT.
>> Jeanine: THE TRUTH IS THE
DEMOCRATS, SO MANY OF THEM ARE
IN DISTRICTS WHERE BIDEN ONE MET
BY DOUBLE DIGITS, THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT A LOT
OF THIS, AND IN THE END, I MEAN,
WHAT YOU HAVE GOT IS A PRESIDENT
NOW WHO IS REALLY A FORCE WITHIN
HIS PARTY SAYING "I'M GOING TO
RUN AGAIN."
"I DID REALLY WELL."
NO MATTER HOW DELUSIONAL HE IS,
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SAY, MAYBE
YOU SHOULD RUN AGAIN, BUT I
DOUBT THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IS
LOOKING TO PROMOTE HIM.
HE IS 82 YEARS OLD IF HE RUNS IN
2024, AND WITH THE DECLINE WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST TWO YEARS,
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT WILL BE
LIKE IN TWO MORE.
>> Greg: JESSICA, LET'S TALK
ABOUT ABORTION.
[LAUGHTER]
HASN'T BIDEN ALWAYS KIND OF BEEN
ABOUT LOW EXPECTATIONS?
RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE --
>> Jessica: HE IS AN
UNDERSTATED GUY.
>> Greg: I AM SAYING IT AS A
BAD THING.
>> Jessica: I GET WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING BUT I AM TURNING IT INTO
A GOOD THING.
THAT IS WHAT WE DO.
HE HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY
UNDERESTIMATED, FROM THE
PRIMARY, INTO WINNING THE
GENERAL ELECTION, AND NOW, THE
DEMOCRATS DID PERFORM ABOVE
EXPECTATIONS BY EVERYBODY.
EVERYONE SITTING AT THE STABLE
HAD A DIFFERENT IDEA OF WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Greg: I WAS SAYING
EVERYTHING HE DOES, HE WAS OKAY
WITH AFGHANISTAN PULL OUT, HE
WAS OKAY WITH MILLIONS OF COVID
DEAD COME OKAY WITH FENTANYL
PULLING THROUGH OUR BORDERS.
IT ALWAYS COULD BE WORSE FOR
JOE BIDEN, AND THAT IS WHY HE
DOES NOT MIND.
>> Jessica: I REALLY DON'T
AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY PART
OF JOE BIDEN THAT THINKS WE LOST
13 SERVICE MEMBERS, THAT HE
THINKS THAT IS OKAY, OR WE HAVE
ONE OVERDOSE DEATH --
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBERS.
>> Jessica: OKAY.
AND HE SAYS "I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH REPUBLICANS," THAT IS
CONSISTENT.
HE GOT INFRASTRUCTURE DONE WITH
THEM AND HE GOT GUN REFORM DONE
WITH THEM.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT REPUBLICANS
THAT YOU CAN WORK WITH, HE IS
TALKING BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
LOST THEIR ELECTIONS, AND THERE
ARE TONS OF INTERESTING THINGS
COMING OUT OF THE EXIT POLLS BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PARTICULARLY STRUCK ME WAS
AMONGST PEOPLE WHO "SOMEWHAT
DISAPPROVE" OF JOE TO PRIDE IN,
THE INDEPENDENTS, THE MODERATES,
MAINSTREAM REPUBLICANS, BUT THEY
COULD NOT GO FOR THE MAGA
CANDIDATES, THEY COULD NOT GO
FOR THE TRUMP ENDORSEMENTS,
WHICH IS WIDE DONALD TRUMP HAS A
36% SUCCESS RATE AND IS FUMING
AT HOME AND BLAMING
MELANIA TRUMP TO FOR PICKING
DR. OZ, AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
A LOT OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE
STAYING TODAY, WINSTON SEARS IN
VIRGINIA SAYING IT IS TIME TO
MOVE ON FROM THIS, SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BECOME POISONOUS FOR THE
REPUBLICAN BRAND.
YOU CAN CALL IT TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME OR WHATEVER
YOU WANT, BUT HIS ASSOCIATION
AND HIS GROWING VISIBILITY IN
THE LAST TEN DAYS OF THIS
CAMPAIGN, I BELIEVE, STRIPPED
REPUBLICANS OF VERY WINNABLE
SEATS.
THERE WERE VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS
WHO WERE ABLE TO PULL IT OUT
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP BECAME A
FORCE IN THIS ELECTION AGAIN.
>> Greg: THAT DEMOCRATS WON,
TOO.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
>> Jessica: WHAT IS A BAD
DEMOCRAT TO YOU?
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A PERSON WHO
WON WHO COULD BARELY SPEAK.
>> Jessica: FIRST OF ALL, THAT
IS NOT TRUE, AND IF YOU LISTEN
TO HIS ACCEPTANCE SPEECH ON
TUESDAY NIGHT, YOU SAW SOMEONE
WHO I THOUGHT WAS EVEN MARKEDLY
IMPROVED FROM WHAT WAS GOING ON
AT THE DEBATE THERE.
AND YES, EARLY VOTING WENT ON
LONG BEFORE THAT, BUT PEOPLE
RECOVER FROM STROKES.
HIS MIND ISN'T -- I'M TALKING TO
MORE THAN YOU.
WE HAVE 3.5 MILLION PEOPLE ALSO
WATCHING.
>> Greg: MORE THAN THAT,
ACTUALLY.
IT WAS ABOUT 5 MILLION
YESTERDAY.
>> Jessica: IT'S ELECTION
SEASON.
ALL THE RATINGS.
THE RATINGS ARE FANTASTIC.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS SOMEBODY WHO
PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA FELT THAT
THEY KNEW, OVER 60% SAID DR. OZ
DIDN'T KNOW THE COMMONWEALTH
WELL ENOUGH TO REPRESENT IT.
HE IS SOMEONE WHOSE VALUES HAVE
BEEN KNOWN, AND THAT IS WHAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA EMPHASIZED WHEN
HE CAMPAIGNED FOR HIM, YEAH, HE
DOES NOT SOUND LIKE HE USED TO
DO, BUT YOU KNOW WHO JOHN
FETTERMAN IS.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHO HE
IS --
>> Jessica: HE LIVES IN --
>> Jesse: HE DOES NOT PAY HIS
TAXES.
THAT IS WHO HE IS, JOHN
FETTERMAN.
>> Jessica: DON'T --
>> Jesse: ENOUGH YOUR MSNBC
WANTED TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Jessica: ONE PERSON ON
MSNBC --
>> Jesse: IS IT?
OUT TO CHECK --
>> Jessica: GOT TO CHECK THE
RUNDOWN?
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN IS A
RESPONSIBILITY DENIER.
HE HAS PROGRAMMED NOT TO TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ANYTHING.
HE WOULD GET UP THERE I
LITERALLY LIKE THE COUNTRY ON
FIRE AND SAY "YOU KNOW WHAT,
PEOPLE PUT ME IN OFFICE TO BURN
STUFF."
"THEY TRUST ME WITH MATCHES"
VEHICLE THE OTHER SIDE WANTS TO
PUT OUT THE
FIRE AND MAKE IT WORSE, THE
FIRE WILL BE OUT NEXT YEAR IN
AMERICA IS GOING TO LIKE THIS
COUNTRY WELL DONE."
THAT IS THE KIND OF GUY WE'RE
DEALING WITH HERE.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
CHANGE WITH REPUBLICANS WHETHER
HE LIKES IT OR NOT THE ARTICLE
NANCY WAS A SHOPAHOLIC.
THEY SPENT $20 TRILLION IN THREE
YEARS AND WONDER WHY WE HAVE
RECORD INFLATION?
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO KEEP
THE PURSE TIGHT, NOT LIKE NANCE,
AND NOT LET HIM SPEND LIKE A
DRUNKEN SAILOR, SO HE SHOULD
KIND OF LIGHTEN McCARTHY WITH
THE GAVEL.
DEAL WITH THE BORDER BECAUSE
REPUBLICAN'S ARE GOING TO
IMPEACH MAYORKAS IF HE DOES NOT
DO ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY THAN HE
IS DOING RIGHT NOW.
THAT WILL ALSO HELP JOE BIDEN.
HE SHOULD BE HAPPY McCARTHY IS
IN THERE.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
HAPPY.
A BALANCED GOVERNMENT IS GOOD.
YO